[Music]
foreign
Holland and Zendaya were just snapped
holding hands in London it's great to
have that support and that love around
you because you need that you know the
lovebirds were spotted at the
supermarket on Wednesday hand in hand
with a coffee in the other that's Tom
rocking a purple backwards cap a hoodie
and tan pants while Zendaya looks casual
and Chic in a black jacket and baggy
jeans I wanted something that was casual
and cool and in case all that hand
holding wasn't cute enough on Sunday Tom
and Zendaya were seen taking a leisurely
stroll with his parents this whole
journey I am blown away to share with my
family honestly this means the world to
me of course the couple is notoriously
private but back in October Tom and
Zendaya were seen touring the Louvre
again holding hands it's an amazing
thing to be able to do you know they've
also popped up in Boston and New York in
recent months and you guessed it lots of
hand holding there too when we're not
working we're always together and uh and
that makes a really great chemistry the
duo went public with their love in 2021
after years of playing koi about their
relationship have you found that it's
hard to date in Hollywood so yeah it's
such a young age of course it is I mean
it's hard today at any age I mean it
doesn't matter you know where you are
either I mean it's just hard to date in
general romance rumors first barked on
the Spider-Man press tour in 2017. fast
forward a few years later
Tom confirmed he and Zendaya are
together and then we got this adorable
moment
just showed up
[Applause]
that's her no no that's I want to see
what she has on can we watch is she
gonna walk down here
it's her let's watch
[Applause]
whip oh she's going in she's going in
she's going in she's gone Stephanie's in
there safe to say Tom's her biggest fan
and these two just keep getting cuter
[Music]